Before we go further, I'd like for us to have a quick blueprint overview so that we can make
sure that everyone understands a few of the blueprint concepts we're going to be making
heavy use of inside of our example. Now the first one is understanding blueprint flow.
Now this is a term that's used to describe how the blueprint graph goes from left to right,
just like you read in English. So no matter what we're doing, we're always going to be
starting at the left hand side. So we'll start here, and then we will go to the right, process
our output, and then we will be able to choose something here at the end. But it's very important
to understand this because this is going to happen a lot inside of our projects. Now there are some
nodes that we will be looking at using as well as some additional nodes here that I just want to
call out. But first off is the node I want to talk about here is the branch. And the branch
allows us to do things on a true or a false. And this is unreal. If then node. So if something is
true, we're going to do this. If something is false, we're going to do this. Notice the condition
here, this allows us to tie this to a variable. So we can have a bunch of different variables,
one that looks for something like, you know, the player has the key. And if they do, then we will
open the door. If not, we'll give them a message that says, you know, you don't have the key. There's
a lot of things that we can do with this one simple branch node, in terms of flow controller,
how our project is going to progress from one area to another. Next, we have a flip flop. So the
flip flop allows us to have something input here. And then what's going to happen is it's going to go
a and then B, and it's going to repeat this behavior for the entire way the project is running. So
I like these because we can put these on a button. And if we click the button, it's going to do
something like turn on the light. And then if we click it again, it will turn off the light
without us having to develop a really complicated trigger to you know, is it been turned on? Yes,
then we reset something. This is just really did we turn it on? Toggle a, did we toggle again,
then toggle B? After that, we have a sequence. Now a sequence allows us to execute a sequence
of events based off of an input. If we want, we can use this add pin here to add more than inputs,
or I should say then outputs and fire off as many things as we want. Next to that, we have a
switch on int. This allows us to add again, additional outputs here, but instead of just
firing them off in succession, this like the sequence node, this allows us to enter an integer
here that will execute that particular output that we have. So if we put a zero, it's going to do
default. If we were to add a pen here and do one, it will do the next one to the next one,
and so on, and so on. Last but not least, we have gate and multi gate net. While we won't be making
use of these nodes in this project, it's just something I wanted to call out, because these do
allow us to do some very complex flow control gates allow us to do actually execution based
conditional checks so we can check for have things been entered into or states and things of that
nature using these. And again, while we don't necessarily utilize them in this particular
tutorial, it is good to know about them. Now, this slide deals with time control, because flow control
is again, how our project is going to deal with data time control is how our project is going to be
dealing with times and turn off things like maybe a countdown for a level, or maybe you're keeping
time to do a time trial or some other nature, but time control is very important. And the first
thing that we can do to control time with our delays. Now, there is a delay, a delay in delay
until the next tick and a retrogable delay. Now, while delays are great when you're prototyping,
the problem with any of these delays is that once you have started the delay, there is no way to stop
it or restart it or go around it. A delay, if you say, let me put a delay in the five seconds,
there is no way to stop that delay from happening, you have to wait for the full five seconds, so
you can't say interrupt it. Now, if you want something that you could interrupt or something
that's just a lot easier to keep time with, there are actual two nodes called set timer by event and
set timer by function name, but we're actually going to be utilizing these in our code here to
create a timer for our example in a little bit. But these timer nodes are really cool because
you can set multiple timers for whatever you need. And then anywhere through blueprint,
you can actually call the timer and stop it or start it. So they're extremely useful.
The last thing that I want to talk about is a timeline. So a timeline allows us to
animate between two values. So let's say we wanted to go between zero and one, we can use a timeline
to animate that going from zero to one. The last thing that I want to talk about here is with a
delay, just a little pro tip. If you set the duration down here to zero, that's actually going
to give you a one frame delay. And that's actually one of the best use cases for a delay is if you
are trying to act as a single frame delay, you can set it to point zero, and it will act as a
single frame delay. And this is great if you need to slow spawning down or delay something just by
a single frame until something else happens. This can be a really great way to do that inside of
blueprints.